hi guys welcome to seize to about sky J
and since this is season two I am gonna
celebrate by doing something that I've
never done before what
that's right guys over 21 episodes thank
you so much for watching and you know
what thank you so much for all of the
amazing comments all of the video
responses but the craziest thing that I
think that I love the most about during
this episode is when I get video
responses from parents so will setting
their small children or just seeing my
theme song
hey you're 5 now I'm doing something a
little different this episode because
I'm getting all of these videos from the
nikon festival contest now if you don't
know what the contest is basically it's
a contest where you upload a video of
your day 140 seconds or less and you
could potentially win $100,000 what
would you do with $100,000 let me tell
you what I would do
don't forget you can enter the contest
until December 15th that's not much time
left anyway enough of that here are a
few of my favorite videos
what's your favorite old TV show one of
my favorite old TV shows is full house
best show ever
what does the subject in school that you
most disliked math class and Spanish
video dica I've already established
that's the only Spanish word that I know
but there's an app for that where is the
library my first question is with panda
bear Z are you serious
bamboo one of my three favorite Mac
applications tweeting for Twitter mail
plane for Gmail and stickies for making
notes
in the last episode I asked you guys
what your holiday traditions were here
were a few of your responses
so my question to you for this episode
is if you actually won the hundred
thousand dollars from the nikon contest
what would you do with it and now to
celebrate the second season in ask IJ I
give you a techno remix of the ask a
theme song and a little music video oh
yeah joy and subscribe